hello and welcome back to the 60th ever
episode of the iced coffee hour podcast
i am kelly stamps
and so far this podcast has made 71
129 and 52 cents that was actually
really good
can i just say i think that was the best
introduction you've ever had on the
podcast
that was actually really good i was
impressed you had a little time to
practice though
yeah i think when i just get a mic i
feel
unstoppable first i was all nervous once
i started
i just i'm a national born performer
it's easy
well thank you so much for coming all
the way to las vegas from
where what floor florida up in the
everglades
i think you're our farthest guest ever
to travel is that is that true graham
is it i think it is florida yeah we had
no one else come from another country i
guess not
no florida is another country it may as
well be
it may as well be it's it's wild out
there but
this is exciting to have you on because
this started when you posted a video
about how you spend what was it you
breaking down your income sources how
you make 40 000
a month and i took that as an
opportunity
to monetize it for myself yes so i did a
reaction video to you making and
spending 40 000
a month and then he started getting into
your content and you're doing some
really great videos about
minimalism that uh it's just it's it's
very
relatable it's very approachable it's
nothing like
too fancy it's just but it's really
simple content that people really like
how did you get started doing that and
what was your reaction by the way when
you saw my video
and in my video by the way i was like
jack we got to bring her down we gotta
meet her
and then here you are yes well i
well first thank you for having me here
yes
my clone jack why are you wearing that
wig i just noticed that i think when
people like
grow old with each other they start to
look like each other like how people say
about their dogs
got it yeah i could see that okay
continue yeah
but i um i guess i started my channel
just as a way to
make myself laugh uh make my delusions
come to life essentially
i first started off on instagram just
doing little skits with
you know different wigs in my household
i did little skits like black
thanksgiving and
what it's like living alone and just
funny things and my friends said start a
youtube channel
so i did and here we are i guess there's
no agenda behind it honestly
i just upload videos to make myself
laugh were you
were you what were you doing when you
first started making these little skits
were you
did you have a job was was just like
during school or like
how old were you when you started it was
2018.
uh well i always had a youtube channel
actually let's go way back
i used to post hotel reviews when i was
a teenager
on youtube because i traveled a lot for
gymnastics are they still up
no i would do anything to find those
videos we would travel a lot for
gymnastics like my mom and i and my dad
so we would go to really middle of
nowhere places like virginia beach
up in the woods or somewhere and we
would say it like days in
quality in but for me it was an
experience like i gotta review this like
i am
anthony bourdain like parts that are
known and i was just very into it
um got a lot of mean comments people
were like come get their child who is
this
what is this person doing i did a back
handspring tutorial i was a kid it's a
little
messy so how old were you when you were
doing 12
12 years old so it's already a vlog yeah
but i didn't actually
start doing my channel until it was
2018. my first ever
official video for my channel was what
to expect at bootcamp
because there's not a lot of videos out
there there's not a lot of military
related content creators besides one
person named kyle got at the time so i
thought why not show
a girl going into this really boyish job
of avionics
so i did a video of what to pack what
not to pack um
and you don't have your cell phone for i
believe two and a half months
so it was fun for me to share with the
world oh this is what you're going to
experience if you actually sign up for
the military and from there people
thought it was funny they weren't as
interested in the military advice they
were just like this girl's hilarious we
like
your take and my reenactment of my uh
base commander
he would always yell at me apparently i
have a smirk on my face
that's the smirk it's just me resting
he's like staples
airmen staples aaron's staples i'm like
sir airmen stance reports it stamps
we never saw him again rumor is he quit
because of me
did you always have the intention to to
join the military or was this more like
a decision you wanted to experience this
i wanted to go in as an officer after
college but after taking
like a year and a half well actually two
years at santa monica college
in santa monica right from i realized i
just want to make money right away
so in addition to youtube i said well i
just feel like i kind of have that
thing that makes money yeah so i just
went and got a retail job
like everybody else does in santa monica
just started working on the channel
lived at home at the time so i was able
to actually
pull in all the creative juice i needed
because i think if i started now
living alone it would be harder because
i was able to take more risks
living at home and that's how i got
there i guess i just all my funniest
videos were made
in my house my mom was always downstairs
i'm like shh
she'd make one sound i'm like i'm trying
to make content so those are my most
popular it was
yeah so so get this so when i first
started i was making videos at the
oppenheim group
late at night and i'd purposely wait for
jason and brett to leave and make sure
they were gone
because here's the thing sometimes they
would go to the gym and be like okay
they're gone like i'm gonna at least
have an hour
they'll come back like five minutes
later and then they'll just be down in
the computer it's like working
and i'll wait there i'll wait there
it'll be like 10 o'clock and i'm still
like waiting
10 30 still waiting he'll leave be like
okay now i got
now i got a chance to film there was one
point it was and we had this thing where
if the door opened there was like a beep
beep
like that like a little alarm thing that
would go off yeah and so i was filming
upstairs it's so embarrassing this is
before i told
anybody i was making videos at all and i
had the camera set up with a light
and it was like 10 p.m at night and uh
i'm filming i'm in the middle of like
just talking about something and i hear
the bbb and the door opens up and it's
someone from the office like walking
downstairs and i'm sitting here like
with the mic on
with the camera and i'm just like hoping
they don't see me
i don't know like is it weird i don't
say hi
thankfully i basically hit upstairs they
left and i could resume filming but it
was
nerve-wracking like if someone had
walked in on me filming so i know that
that just like anxiousness about that
yeah and my mom respected my privacy but
she was just like
kelly who is actually watching you do
these kpop tutorials i said
my number one fan is in uzbekistan he
respects me can you disrespect me jersey
so yeah i mean i'm thankful that i had
to work around other noises and i had
multiple roommates
once i moved out of home and here i am
today got it so you were making those
videos how much were you
making back then was it three cents a
day
when i was at home so it was a very i
would say steady build between
2018 up until 2020. i was first making
nothing um it was three cents four cents
12 cents was a big day for me i said i'm
gonna go to the nail shop
this month and then uh 2020
january 10th exactly nice story time
video
which was totally impromptu about going
on a bumble date
i actually my mom had no idea about this
video until her co-workers
said are you aware that your daughter is
like famous now or something but
it was a video about me meeting someone
on bumble and he showed up
kind of bait and switched me that video
how did he bait him wait you gotta tell
this story
oh we haven't seen it no you know watch
okay well
this one it's controversial which is
good it kind of struck people so i think
youtube said all right this is making
people mad
it's making us money let's make our
money so it just worked out okay um
i started off in my car filming on my
like potato iphone like hello everybody
i'm angry
i just drove to italy i drove to my home
basically
met a guy off bumblebee century city
yeah okay you already know the one
century city yeah
this guy met me so i like typically
older guys
it's okay i can work with it i typically
like older people just because like with
my experience like i mentioned i kind of
always been working
i just relate to people who are kind of
yeah what they're doing jack is very
mature for
yeah he is listening i never notice any
sort of different like like i treat jack
like i would like ages
you don't notice the difference no like
maybe i treat you like like i would like
a 50 year old right
didn't you say something i would i would
not say so
i mean alex what do you think does he
treat me like a 50 year old
macy i mean i hear you like i think he
just treats you like anybody
else oh yeah the biggest the biggest
thing for me would be the uh
the lack of awareness for laundry
and for laundry for ironing clothes
those two things from yeah
so anyway yeah i like men older do their
laundry whatever
sure um and everything was all great and
at the end of the day he goes oh by the
way
um do you like kids i said well
yeah i like steak but i don't eat it all
the time you know i like kids i don't
particularly want to
be around them i don't what are you
asking this where he goes well
truth is i have a little bugger i'm like
what's that like
an injury he said no i have a son and i
really care about him and they go okay
okay he's like you look mad i'm like no
and it became not just one bugger he
said we'll actually have multiple kids
and i'm just sick of meeting la women
who are judgmental
and don't want anyone to deal with kids
and i'm just like on my profile it
actually says no kids
because i know but like i just was
thinking that you'd be the one who said
that on your profile yeah i said no kids
so two things number how old was he 28.
28. i think and to put no kids is that a
common thing
because i feel like no kid like it's
they won't say no kids yeah that means
you don't want it so
there's on at the time bumble had an
option where you could say
your plans for family don't want want
want and have more
or haven't don't want more mine said
don't want
but i mean but obviously i'm yelling
back i'm gonna say that sure i might pop
out a bunch of little stamps
but that just means i don't want to deal
with his being how young i was i was
23 and i made that video no 22.
but either way he i felt that he didn't
lie because he didn't say
he had kids or didn't have kids he just
sprung it on me at the end
and it felt kind of like misled
and he basically got really upset at me
but that's the video i told it in a
really funny way i get upset
oh he just said well you're just
judgmental like the rest of women wait
but you
so you retorted and you said oh i don't
like that oh no i didn't say anything i
just said okay
he's like your voice is going up like no
not what you're saying
he's like you look happy i said okay
well to be honest i said if i had an
option between meeting a man who
has children already or doesn't just for
the sake of me not having to like worry
about having to play stepmother
at this time in my life being a literal
child who just learned how to make my
own doctor's appointment
i would obviously prefer one who doesn't
but like i would now date someone if
they did have them
because i have more experience but still
like i mean i think any
person generally would agree with that
and actually these youtubers made a
response to it
his name is abba and preach they're
really well known it's really funny
but um that video blew up because it was
controversial
and so many people were like on this
side and this side and people were
making assumptions in the comment
section like
so what's going to happen when you have
children like well i would meet someone
who also has children
and or you would stay with them yeah
children like everyone just disappears
i'm like yeah
i have a good effect on men
the stamp stays with them i don't know i
have a pretty good track record but
it was just a funny video and it was so
random and out of the balloon it was
filmed on an iphone 5 that's the
funniest part i have so many other
nicely made videos about like new york
and my experience but that one
randomly went off three months later in
january
then it kind of worked as a trickle-down
effect so then i went to the uh
the end page where you can add in the
next video link so then i added
a new york city uh interview video where
i interviewed men with my spatula
and people said wow this trick's funny
so then just went down that route
why didn't you go down the route of more
dating stories but first i want to thank
our sponsor
skillshare i absolutely love learning
new skills in my personal time whether
it's improving my photography
learning new editing techniques or even
trying something completely new like
graphic design i actually personally
remember using skillshare to learn
graphic design from the start
when i first launched my business i
truly believe all humans were born to
create in one way or another whether you
last picked up a paintbrush yesterday or
in grade school
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership
with meaning they offer so much to
explore projects to create and support
from fellow creatives
one class i look forward to taking is
youtube success
script shoot and edit with mkbhd it's a
class taught by marquez brownlee one of
my all-time favorite youtube creators
and skillshare is for everyone whether
you want to be a dabbler
a pro a hobbyist or a master you are
creative explore your creativity today
and get a one month trial of premium
membership
for free to get started go to
skillshare.com
iced coffee that's skillshare.com
iced coffee thank you so much skillshare
for sponsoring the video and back to the
podcast
because i gotta say they're funny dating
everyone
loves that this is this has been the
highlight of the
of the vlog is just jack and dating you
combine the two
and it's we the retention rate you
literally see retention goes up
as soon as it's like anything jack and
dating retention all the way through the
roof and then as soon as we switch
topics
why not double down on that and be like
okay this is this is my
this is my infinite monetization loop
i'm gonna go and bumble even more
go on more dates and just get like just
share stories if i did go down that
route that would be really great
actually
however i find that whenever is an
unpopular opinion
whenever people have these dating
channels most of them are single for a
reason i find
when they give out advice like just see
you now don't ever text a guy back at
501 pm you have to wait
i just don't want to go down that route
of preaching to people what they should
and should not be doing because i think
everyone is different but it would be
story times
it would oh story time okay you would
just
i don't want to look like a crazy chick
who just talks about men on the internet
i have three videos that are doing so
well though
yeah that's true i feel like once you
start going down that rabbit hole drama
channels
all that people see you as yeah and then
also once you did end up getting a
boyfriend
then it would kind of like i mean how
where is your chair i would belong to
the streets i would be walking down and
people will be like oh you all saw that
video
man your ex bro that was good it was
good
and i knew this guy is is it good enough
for you
[Laughter]
like i have like friends and i was
walking around with my friend it was
just
his arm and people were making all these
assumptions about him because of my past
videos
some guy said he's not going to treat
you well it's just my guy friend's
forearm
i said from the forum you can tell yeah
he's not going to take care of you
he's got three kids like he's gonna be a
problem for you you should
should take me and they're like in
kansas or something okay but
not a bad idea at all if anything it
would be fun to sprinkle those in
but i just don't want to be known as the
person because you know there's also bad
stories about women i have to keep it
fair to some degree i don't want to
paint all men as bad even though florida
they are rough why what's what's wrong
with
what's wrong with florida man when you
mix the heat in florida
with you know women because we can't
really wear too many layers there it's
really hot
in addition to there being many
different cultures in florida just
blended into one
you get different types of customs for
example i was in publix which is the one
market we have and i was just walking
down the aisle and some man said
chocolate i said excuse me he said
chocolate
he said that to you i said what are you
he goes chocolate
your skin's so smooth i said oh you're
you're complimenting me he goes yeah
i oh okay thank you and he just stared
at me like
so in his where he comes from oh i spoke
to him he's from
israel okay so i live in a very like
yeah i don't know the community is
interesting it's half jewish half cuban
and then there's me so i literally stand
out like chocolate so when they see me
they just don't know how to act but you
know if i come out here people are like
hi how are you doing
lost in experience they just don't say
anything they're like they saw jack be
like vanilla
and my friend and i together they said
caramel and chocolate oh god
it happens they said that yeah people
call you out by your appearance like
they say legs
to me because my legs are 99 my body do
you know the peter griffin meme
where his legs go all the way up that's
me if i stand up have you seen it i
don't know if i have
you know comment below if you know that
we'll put a picture up here peter
griffin the legs go all the way up
okay so that's what it looks like when i
wear a skirt got it okay
so anyway so so bumble stories start
blowing up for you
yes uh is that when you started doing it
full-time
not necessarily so i didn't really plan
the full-time thing i was already
uploading
two times a week since the beginning it
was more like the income
passed a certain amount that i could
live off of
it was about april actually this is
pretty recent
of 2020 when i said you know what mother
i'm tired of you yelling at me about the
fork in the sink that is your
fork if you're watching that is your
fork it's not my fork
she likes to leave dishes in the sink
when i sleep with her and
she would just like leave anyway petty
stuff so
i said you know what i make exactly
five thousand two hundred dollars after
taxes that's only this amount but i'm
gonna move out
so i went to new york city started
making content the same way i didn't
change anything
i just started vlogging more about new
york my experience there
it kind of changed from funny story
times to
let me show you the city and this is my
experience living here not knowing what
i'm doing
you know what when you mentioned april
of 2020
that's when the youtube algorithm i
think really started recommending your
content because i think at the time
when i first saw your channel it came up
recommended to me
i think you maybe had a hundred thousand
subscribers ish yeah and remember i sent
your channel the macy
and i'm like macy check out this channel
i don't know what you were doing but the
videos kept getting recommended
and uh and it was just they were good
videos
uh nothing like like r-rated like no
swearing or anything nothing
inappropriate it was just really simple
good videos
why do you think they took off the way
they did
so i'm used to seeing myself every day
and i'm used to
just waking up and just existing but
according to the comment section
people keep saying it's so nice you're
such a breath of fresh air that you're
just yourself on camera
and that i apparently don't try to talk
with an extra high pitched voice
or seem extra excited like hi guys um
it's kind of like alex is cracking up
over there
because that's that's ground yeah
with finance you got to make it exciting
so you got to take yourself
plus at 50 yeah because already uh you
lose like 20
of yourself just being on camera you're
less exciting so you have to and when
you're providing such high value content
like that
people naturally don't want to listen
they just want to hear how do i become
rich exactly how do i become rich i
don't understand they skip to the end
yeah
so you can do that hi guys
but um with my channel i think it's just
that i truly just depicted
what i was really going through in each
phase because currently i'm in a phase
where i said okay i'm
i want something new i need to either
launch a podcast or a second channel
or have a business like you suggested uh
so i think it just took off because
people said i'm like a friend in their
head that is what they keep saying
and i've met so many other youtube
people when i lived in new york city
all of them said they've never been
approached as much as i do i got
approached five to six times a day
living in manhattan and people feel so
comfortable coming up to me
because they feel like i am their friend
so i think it's just that i offer
advice or at least talk i see what other
people are thinking but they won't say
it
yeah and i don't apologize for it it is
odd like i remember when i first started
like watching your videos the content is
so easily digestible
like you could just like benjamin yeah
exactly you could just watch it
and listen you never get bored even if
it's not the most exciting content
for some reason you're just drawn into
watching it and it just it just
works i don't know what it is my friend
said it's my bush baby eyes
because i don't blink and i could tell
you something right now like did you
know that 60
of penguins are actually going extinct
right now in santa monica
and there's a huge short like i believed
you yeah until you said
santa monica got it i don't know i'm
just teasing
you know what i realized alex that
you're wearing two different kinds of
socks
yes but you know what else oh what we
could just sponsor ourselves in this
video how about that
you know what that sounds great i always
like my own posts anyway
me too and for a limited time if you
want access to the youtube creator
academy where i go over
exactly what you need to do step by step
to start a youtube channel and turn it
into a business
i will give you 200 off when you use the
coupon code
200 off the link is down below in the
description this is everything that i
have learned about how to grow a youtube
channel what makes a successful title
and thumbnail
everything you need to do along the way
it's all down below in the description
and it's 200
off 200 bucks off 200
but i'm gonna take you up on that deal
because i have this to family to run
wow there we go well thank you guys so
much for watching
enjoy the discount and with that said
let's get back to the video what made
you want to make that
income video i actually didn't want to
you didn't want to
no i know why i did because yes but
also i wish i had someone
like that on youtube to be honest when i
was starting to give me a ballpark of
what i should be earning
so it wasn't really i actually i'm not
gonna say i regret making the video
i just don't think it's anybody's
business how much you make or what you
vote or any of that stuff however
i got nothing but thank you kelly thank
you for telling me because i was
low-balled so much
in the beginning uh when i had
like 30 000 subscribers i should have
been getting like some brand deals by
then but people were just trying to send
me like
wigs for free and like hair extensions
and stuff so
i made that video just to say okay
people this is what you can be earning
just so you know because every day i
wake up like what
on earth i can't believe i make a living
just being myself on camera
i want other people to know that they
can do this too and more
how do you get started with the
minimalism aspect was that when you
moved to new york you didn't have
furniture and you're like
minimalist no actually i
i think oh who would i watch i watched
some marie condo video she's really well
known for
fashion like organization and
there's a thing called the konmari
method where she cleans out how do you
know have you seen this before macy okay
women tend to watch her a lot she's very
popular i lived at home
and my mom has a lot of clothes like
we're very close but she's
she's super into fashion she has so much
and we moved
after my parents got divorced and i saw
how hard it was for her to move
i thought wow that can't be me ever so i
went to my closest crossroads trading
post
buffalo exchange place took all of my
clothes sold it
realized most of those clothes i never
even wore and most of them weren't even
worth the investment in the first place
it was such a pain trying to sell
everything on poshmark but i made about
six hundred dollars from
a gigantic closet and realized oh would
i just take that 600 and just buy a few
statement pieces that will last me
forever
so that's kind of how i've been since
when i moved to boston though i did
go shopping because i started getting
bigger youtube paychecks so i kind of
got addicted to shoes but then i sold
them all again because i realized this
shouldn't work
so you told me that you have like
six articles of clothing right yeah this
is one of them it's
my favorite it's like a t-shirt but it's
a dress and i can dress it up
day to night but how do you oh let me
correct that
six actual like outfit articles of
clothing like dresses i have a dress
really nice i have thermals to go to bed
in
and under layers base layers but in
florida you really don't need that many
clothes
because i wear like the dresses i wear
have to get dry cleaned
so they don't really like get dirty like
uh cashmere stuff like that just doesn't
get soiled easily i don't know and i
really do have dresses that go from day
to night
i just have shoes shoes that change
would you trust jack with your laundry
no okay here's why why not i have silks
i have cashmere i have linen blends
what do you do what's easy what do you
do with silk lingerie uh okay so one the
washer at my house
there is there so my mom no
i hand them to my mom no there's a
setting that says
delicates so i'll spin it to delicates
and i'll put all this stuff in and then
i study
do you use regular detergent or a
special type
i use the expensive one tied
tied detergent sorry and then of course
you need to add the fab
fabric softener the fabric piece of
paper yes
uh in the dryer like first that's the
first time i've ever heard someone say
softener is that what it's called
softener
fast it's like a quiet right you add
that to the dryer and then you take it
out and
you're done oh and when you dry put it
on delicate setting
wow did he practice this i think he did
wow
no i don't know i added to the dryer dry
sheets in the dryer not the washer okay
i will say that's actually not bad
personally i like to hand wash my
clothing
because it saves a lot of water and i
don't have that many outfits so again
it'd be a huge waste but i still like to
go down to my garage and wash because
there's always some sort of animal in
the garage
it's fun going downstairs in florida
yeah you're right
uh there is a certain wash i use
delicates but i usually just hand wash
everything and hang dry it because it
takes care of
the clothes better and i don't have to
buy new clothes yes
you ever heard of that grime delicates
have you
[Laughter]
so what was your reaction then to
watching my reaction to you did you know
who graham was before he reacted to
i will admit i don't watch your channel
like clockwork i don't watch anyone's
like clockwork i watch
cat videos and airplane stuff but i know
very well who you are
i feel like you look the same in person
but
like yeah that would worry me but what
like i feel like you haven't
aged you've had a channel for so long
you're like the benjamin
button no no no i'm getting wrinkles
around here okay yeah well it's just
kind of funny because i'm like oh i'm
sitting next to the person i watch now i
see how people feel when they meet me
but um i know about your channel i know
about your main channel yeah
i didn't know about the iced coffee our
podcast i thought it was really funny
once i started watching it i thought it
was insightful a way to
share knowledge of people like me who
don't know anything about investing or
personal finance in general
but i knew you're going to make a
response people were telling me graham's
going to respond to this if you make a
video so i was wearing my instagram
followers i said
you guys keep asking me they want they
feel more intimate with me they don't
feel like i'm being
gaudy by saying oh i earned this amount
of money it's more like
i've always been very transparent from
2018.
i earned three cents today i remember
this so when i made it i saw your
response i said oh okay
it was a surprise i said this is gonna
respond i know that you were you you
really clicked like i was gonna
you weren't nervous everyone seems
nervous like i'm about to like rail into
well you know
yeah i didn't answer a lot of things
because i didn't realize in the moment i
should
like you ask what happens with the rest
of your money yeah um
also i didn't leave if i included my
cost of flying
i would have been more nervous because
i'm very protective over that but again
it's something i invest a lot of money
into
because it's my hobby yeah i wasn't
nervous
i know that my car lease is expensive
and
i feel kind of indifferent about it i
like the car gives me confidence i was
only worried about that getting chewed
apart because everyone chews me apart
from my car
but in florida
convertible yes it's so fancy
but also i might trade it in and get
like a little suv or something
you can do that yeah yeah oh i mean
literally without it you can trade it
and get a different car but i can also
do like a lease swap
okay but i wasn't nervous i was just
excited because i feel like everyone
told me it's a milestone if you make it
in the seat
i'm like oh wow they said i'm so proud
of you
someone said i feel like you're my
daughter i'm so proud of you on grounds
okay gosh that's nuts it's a milestone
yeah wow so where does the extra money
go
i am very old school i'm very much like
my dad
he was very stubborn it better not be
cash
cash no actually a savings account that
doesn't earn any interest with wells
fargo
worse than that i think savings accounts
are completely useless that's a checking
account it's all
it's all no no it's actually not it's
well the worst you could do is a wells
fargo checking account oh no i have just
typical i don't want to tell people my
bank just in case someone some hacker
finds a way in
but it's
which one is it
account they're really good yeah so i
have a business account for uh well i
mean they kind of bleed into each other
but
i have a business account which is just
right my youtube earnings go into i
guess and then i have a personal account
which is just it still is oh no i just
said it
i meant i love td bank um it's just in
my checking account but
i a long time ago actually
like did dogecoin when it first came out
didn't put in that much i wish i did
because now it's not a joke anymore i'm
like oh there's stitch quite
millionaires
how much did you put in dogecoin just
300. and what did it turn into
i think it was like 1300 and you sold it
13. yeah
what would that have been worth now oh i
feel like well it's hard to tell
i would think probably at least
something tells me maybe 13 000. yeah
how long ago did you buy this was
2017. we know this is 2018.
okay no it'd be worth a lot yeah
18 that would have been uh it would be
worth at least like 45 grand
yeah that would have because it was a
fraction of a cent back then mm-hmm
yeah yeah that was like point zero
zero two cents that was a lot of money
back then point two cents or something
like that
yeah and i i'm someone who's just you
know i didn't get the finance talk from
my parents so even doing that was like
whoa
this must be some pyramid scheme i don't
understand this this
this investing thing but um yeah so i
just keep it all in savings because i
wanted to honestly just make a huge
risky
a yolo a gamble yeah no not all of it
i just mean for me i'm like i'm talking
like 20 000
to 50 000 dollars just higher i mean
that's
that is a lot so i'm guess at this point
there's got to be six figures in that
account just sitting there not doing
anything
that's a big opportunity because the
market has gone up in the last year it's
like 20 30 yeah so take whatever you
have
30 is basically how much you missed out
of by not investing your money
and i didn't know i didn't well i knew i
just didn't know where to go to and
actually robin hood app worked with me
on a sponsorship and that's when i found
out about it like actually
how to invest i still don't know to be
honest but they have a program called
like
learn robin hood you don't need any of
that yeah but i worked with them so i
just use the robin hood app i just have
something in s p what's it called
vanguard
whatever vanguard sure just that i don't
even look at it to be honest
um i don't know what i'm waiting for i
think it's just a fear of
losing the money no it's not going to
happen like that
the worst the worst is probably going to
happen if you're in an s p 500 is like
it goes down the market goes down 50
that's the worst that's gonna happen
most likely in the next
who knows how many years at some point
it's going to go down and if that
happens recovery but you're going to
keep buying in it's not like you're just
going to yeah once and then never again
yeah and also there are bigger problems
than your portfolio if the s p 500 goes
down 50 listen as long as you're making
youtube as long as you make money
whatever that investment is worth in the
mean it doesn't make any difference so
if i were you
i would take of that it's a lot of money
i would imagine take
70 percent of it even half half just
because i take half of it
put it all in the s p 500 that's it not
with robin hood
not with robin not with robin really get
get a brokerage
public that has get public where you
could get a free stock down below in the
description
use code graham and it's worth all the
way up to 70 dollars eight
very sponsored a hundred dollars on the
platform someone get a free stock of
tesla
i will i'll be public then but no uh for
for honestly for like
but this is good but actually get the
freeze dog in public
now my point being uh if i were to
invest
more than like a hundred two hundred
thousand dollars i want a brokerage
where i know i could call them up on the
phone if i have any issues
all the other brokerages are great like
i know people who have seven figures on
robin hood
there's nothing wrong with that it's
just for me i'd rather have a phone
number yeah
um so that's what i would do former mr
kelly stamps was a that was his job
and he was the one who's giving me
advice he's like you should just put it
all
in like i don't trust you stan but he's
the one who's telling me that
same advice wait so when did he tell you
to put it all in oh this was like
not all in all of it but he was saying
if i you know go off and become a
commercial pilot
and just use my youtube money as
investing money this was like
four months ago so you would well think
two months ago it's not so bad actually
you would be so yeah so four months ago
you would be up to date
like ten twelve percent which is still i
mean that stinks
that's it ten percent just for five
minutes of work
yeah i would do that now because what
what else is going to happen is that if
you don't do it now
it's easy to put it off and put it off
and it gets scarier because the more the
market goes up the more it's like cool
whoa now it's even higher so i would
just recommend take
half take half okay put it in the market
let it be don't ever look at it again
and
and psychologically too just treat it
like that money's gone
and then now what's in your savings
account is still going to be a lot of
money and then just continue adding on
to that
but and then start investing on a
consistent basis take like five ten
grand a month
just keep buying the same thing and then
keep the rest of the money in your
savings
i kind of see my youtube income as i
mean it's real obviously but
it just doesn't seem real to me like how
do i earn that much
so i just want to play around with it
because i'm i just
like i i'm i'm not in all of it i'm not
going to be like the game where's the
golden nugget
put it all in marty but uh yeah so i'm
willing to finally start investing now
that i have a grasp of
oh it's not you know i'm not gonna be
crying in the street like i lost
everything
yeah here's the thing with youtube is
i've seen how sporadic it could be yeah
and i've seen just how quickly it could
go
from like great and you get one video to
get shadow banned
for like no reason at all and then the
entire channel drops like 20 30 percent
and you realize like oh geez
with youtube it could be like the
highest of highs the lows to blows and
i've seen so many channels just
out of nowhere for no reason just just
they just the whole channel just nose
dives and then they get like they're
like why am i even gonna bother
they move on to something else yeah so i
wouldn't i wouldn't yolo any money
until you have more money than you
really know what to do with like
years this is more like a three four
year plan
right the algorithm so far has been very
kind to me
i think it'll continue to be kind but
you just you never know
yeah yeah all it takes is my my opinion
is it's the algorithm could change at
any moment
and uh you gotta prepare for that so
i've always prepared like
next month is gonna be the last month
and then it hopefully it's not
right yeah i think we should probably
circle back to expenses so um
back to your 40 000 a month income so
you said that you spend a lot of it on
flying but you didn't disclose that in
your video
no i don't know if we're talking about
like because you're talking about
becoming a pilot like flying flying or
if we're talking about
traveling flying no i
hello everybody i have been a
recreational pilot for a long time
you can't actually take your solo test
until you're 17.
i believe of parental consent but um
i've been dabbling in it for many years
the thing is i already had money set
aside for that so none of it came from
youtube
until like just recently just to pay for
some new hours i've been doing but
um it hasn't been coming out of my
recent youtube money i put aside 10 000
many years ago a pilot's license for
personal use is about
14 000 i'm paying 8 800 for mine
i already paid up front um i just have
to pay for
airplane rental which is like 147
dollars an hour and
some fees for the faa to make sure i'm
not what airplane is 100
something dollars an hour oh a cessna
172 a really old one
and that's a lower rate because the
school owns the plane so they're
it's it's kind of complicated but it
doesn't belong to the school someone
like you just bought a cessna
and they're renting it out to the school
but it's scary to drive and
drive to fly an old plane i actually
trust them more
because we already know the problems
with it similar to avionics like you
know
i would feel safer i mean i'd feel a lot
more comfortable in the gulf stream if
you have a gulf stream find me around
but a cessna i know what's wrong with it
and
there are notes that were given in a
plane like okay this one has a problem
with the aileron
well that would be a really bad problem
you don't want to do that but uh these
things are worked on constantly so now
is the 147 an hour does that include gas
or is that just like
i don't pay for fuel actually the flight
school covers that
unless they're yeah it's like in the
cost so 147 an hour and then how many
hours would you say you do this per
session
i spend more time on the ground training
but i would do
lately it's been only three hours a week
flying which doesn't sound like a lot
but when you're in the air for three
hours like one whole hour above florida
doing stalls which is when you there's a
power on cell or a power off stall we're
basically practicing all the worst
maneuvers that can possibly happen to a
plane
recovering from that because the pilot
that flew me over here for example from
florida
has to know what to do if the engine
goes out so
that's why the expensive cost is there
it's just renting
a plane if you stall the plane there's
someone else there if you don't know
what to do that they'll take over for
you right
sometimes yes what it means sometimes so
we are doing solo soon so the path to
getting a personal licenses you first
are doing ground school where you're
learning the aerodynamics of the plane
the forces of it why it flies how it
actually flies which is the part that's
so exciting to me
how does a plane even fly here don't get
it
it's metal and it's in the sky don't
understand getting thrust
you're getting thrust and then because
the way the wings are situated it's
naturally going to
lift up it's a tiny little thing if you
ever listen when your parents are like
drive on the freeway and you stick your
hands down you do this and your hand
goes give me your hand
so this is the wing right this
is a little thing it's called an airfoil
an airfoil is any shape that generates
lift
basically yeah so there's wind coming
here
okay high pressure moves
faster yeah yeah so basically when
you're flying forward
the wings are generating drag here
lift and there's weight so when the four
forces are combined
and you know there might be flaps which
never have everyone take off but you
know
it's hard to explain but the wind the
wind is going to push up against the
wings
yeah lift up the plane i'm just
surprised those those propellers can
spin fast enough oh they're very fast i
guess
i can take you to my plane it's very
fast it's faster than you think
but i'm only allowed to fly one plane
but yeah so i have an instructor
we're currently in stall training which
it just it makes me so uncomfortable
because
people die sometimes doing it but i love
it if i'm going to die anyway
i mean i have to when i die i want to be
in a plane
you do yeah how so like in a crash
i don't want to die in a plane i mean if
i do die when i die
i hope it's doing something that i love
oh okay wouldn't you want to
do wouldn't you want to die like like 90
or 100 years old just like peaceful
tired
surrounded by like that's how graham
wants to die
i don't know in your sleep 75 is good
for me
i don't know that sounds terrible but if
you're like really able at 75. like
you're able to like run around and be
all crazy
young at 75 now yeah i i just
i don't know i'm kind of good like
i feel that i my heart is so full i'm so
happy with all my hobbies
i just i'm just really excited to just
live in the moment
and i just want to do what i love
forever see but like i love reef
aquariums i wouldn't want to
die in one i'd rather that just be a
thing
well you cannot die in one but maybe die
like admiring one yeah
or like fixing one kind of i'm just
saying i'm not scared of it
i don't know yeah i don't know it's a
little a little more of it so how much
have you spent on that
um 8 800 exactly it's not bad
no and then here's where it gets
expensive so if i just stop there
totally fine i can just buy a little
plane they range their cost
is very vast an old cessna the little
planes that you see
i'll insert a picture for you alex i'll
put one mine um
they can be as cheap as 100 000 or they
can go up to
like 600 000 if they're new obviously
they're more expensive
but then you have to pay for the hanger
uh a mechanic
maybe an avionics person so that's why
most people just rent a plane yeah
um if i want to be a commercial pilot
that's what i'm kind of grappling with
now it's
this is where you're gonna this is why i
didn't mention this in the video
if i want to go and become let's say a
delta airlines pilot i'm going to have
to invest at least one hundred thousand
dollars
to earn get this starting salaries maybe
not for delta but in general are around
twenty nine thousand dollars wow no
yeah yeah seriously yeah commercial
pilots are
they they make not enough money i feel
like
for the safety of hundreds of people on
an airplane
there's many reasons for it so why does
the school cost so much
why do they make so little because
because that would assume now there are
a surplus yeah of pilots who all want to
fly planes
no one well it's it's a mixture of
different reasons there's a huge dearth
of pilots because hey
most people drop out they're a washout
rate of flight school just
not even just military doesn't mean like
regular what i'm doing is very high
because
it's a lot of studying it's more than
what people realize and i had
so many moments that's why i've been
doing it forever i just never continued
and it's very expensive people don't
realize how expensive it is once you get
past the ppl
instrument rating is another 7 000 or so
commercial license
is about 40 000 or more because you not
only have to rent the plane
you have to accumulate as you know the
amount of hours off the top of my head
let's say 250 hours of flying
do that by the amount of hours to rent
the plane it's
a whole investment it's a very rich old
man's activity
and airlines just don't pay well
i forgot the exact reason for it i heard
that if you're a commercial
pilot like you can make six figures
pretty easily so i know someone actually
lives in my building he's a 747 pilot
i forgot which airline he told me stay
in their kiddo because it's gonna be
worth it
he first did they're called uh i know
the name of it the people who fly across
the beach with banners
he did that for like thirty dollars an
hour then he got hired at sky west
airlines dollars an
hour for those banners in florida they
usually say really bad things
well i mean i want to tell them i can't
i could i could see that being like kind
of
fun to be like i would say saturday
afternoon don't fly around the beach
iced coffee hour yeah you get paid for
it that's good yeah i could fly your
coffee
but still 30 an hour i would assume 100
an hour
yeah um so commuter planes you could
just look this up online alex too you
can see this it's awful
um they start out 29 000 but that's a
gross amount that's not after taxes
that's not after
the hotel stays i mean the airline pays
for it but
this guy started off really bad then he
got hired at american and got 50 000
as a not a captain but a first officer
which is the person who's on the other
seat they still do all the flying too
it's not like one or the other
necessarily but as a captain now
for an international airline he earns
three hundred thousand dollars
so it's a very slow build to becoming a
captain so that's the thing that
most people just drop out about i see so
it's a lot of money to get it
low pay but over the long term you could
make a lot of money
and you're away from your family this
guy's single it's just it's a very
it's someone like me it's meant for me
like i just know so that's why i said i
didn't mention it in the video
because i was like he's gonna get mad at
me i most likely want to be an airline
pilot it's just the only thing i've ever
dreamed of
you don't want to make youtube videos oh
i do i can do both
but why but why listen so but why not
just
make youtube videos and travel like just
why why why do you need to fly the plane
because
i am dead inside just making videos in
my townhouse
waking up every day having to
please everybody and also please the
algorithm and also figure out oh what am
i going to do this week
it's not healthy for me personally to be
surrounded by just social media
i have to have something else going on
even just taking my golf lessons which
i'm so bad at
it just makes my day and then i'm more
motivated to actually make videos
and do you know how cool it would be to
have a woman making videos online about
there was actually a couple people dana
life is an airline pilot
that is like binge-worthy content
it's not relatable being like here's my
matcha tea guys oh today i'm gonna go to
the gym
and oh howie and i are gonna we're like
on the rocks
this is like a typical influencer
boyfriend i don't know i just i want
something more from life
why not but why not just you could do
that as a hobby like like get a cool
airplane
fly it around on weekends you really
want to do a career
starting out at the twenty nine thousand
like
way up like 60 000 a month with youtube
in addition to that
they're not they're not being mutually
exclusive wouldn't that be very
difficult to do both at the same time
social media i've seen quite a few
people fired from their jobs
for mixing the two because they make
youtube videos it would depend where you
work i guess but
there are so many airlines social media
people now there's someone named
like 74 pilot i talked to someone what's
his name
he's really well known there's a lot of
people now it's becoming normal and
actually airlines kind of like it
like i purposely tried to fly american
to meet this one kid um
oh i forgot his name but anyway he's
really young guy and he became a pilot
same thing as me he just put a lot of
money into flying and didn't come from a
whole lot
it's his passion and like when you're
like me you just understand i
have a passion for serving others so for
me if youtube were to just start
paying me only three thousand a month i
would be totally fine i just i
have such a passion for just helping
other people but not enough to be a
nurse i
don't like bloating but but you want to
make a yolo bet too
do you know what do you know what type
of yolo bet and we'll get back to your
question jack not necessarily okay
when i say airline pilot i don't mean
the next two years i mean like
a seven year plan got it i just plan to
fly in the meantime make as much money
as i can of course from youtube and
create other streams of income as well
the
and i mean the yolo plan would be so
that i don't have to worry i want it to
be a stream of income
so that when i am an airline pilot if i
get used to my little audi and
everything i don't feel like oh
like ghetto downsize i'm kidding
but that would be the goal then you'd
have to move to las vegas
it's affordable i'll be the golden
nugget yeah it's nice and affordable
catch me on my slot machine yeah
okay that should be the yolo bat is just
put five thousand dollars across the
slot machines
yeah vlog it i've never gambled before
really you've never gone
wait are you serious wait that means
you're good luck yeah okay
so there's there's a superstition in
vegas especially for women
the first time you gamble you win and
anytime you go to the craft stable and
like you don't know how to roll the dice
mace you did this too i don't
know how to roll the dice you roll it's
just like number after
number after number after number you'll
see all the guys around the
just they they take out more money in
their pockets
it's a thing but it's true the
superstition is true most of the time
that people will bet on it
so if if you gamble i will i will put
money on that okay
we can go to my hotel i'll gamble i sat
at the machine i was just like
this looks complicated and you didn't so
you've never put money in a machine
never wow never i have a friend in
boston who there's a
big casino it's so random they have a
win casino like right in
kind of outside of cambridge so there's
like beautiful hover then there's the
wind
and people go there and gamble all the
time and he's like i gotta take you with
me
good luck so it's not my first time here
so if you let's say you were in a a
commercial plane
just traveling somewhere let's say
something happens to the pilot
will you be able to like swoop in and
save everyone
it depends what's wrong at this basic
level knowledge that i have of someone
who's just put in many hours
towards a ppl i actually
i think it depends it depends i
literally know how to
like fly it and land a plane the cockpit
varies though
i have to take 10 minutes sometimes to
find out where the fuel gauges are
just in my cessna so if let's say the
engine is out
i could probably find it in my faa
regulations book which is like this
thick
there's always an answer somewhere in
there but that is actually i want to say
it's a goal like i'm not going to hope
that a pilot like dies on a plane or
anything
but i would love to be like yes yes does
someone say pilot like i always find a
way to insert that i'm a pilot into
something someone's like
so many shoes thanks i'm a pilot wait
what i'm a pilot
so i think that's all of our dreams
actually again i just like saving and
helping people
like captain fix a broken boy but you're
not broken you're seeing all right
you could fix jack how would you fix
jack
what about me would you fix see i like
i don't mean projects in a bad way i
would open his eyes to the culinary arts
world
i love amazing food i talked about wagyu
steak yeah
i would show him traditional wagyu steak
like how to make it on my komodo joe
grill
uh lots of travel i just think travel
opens up i haven't even left this
country by the way i've only gone to
like canada and mexico
mexico but you know what you know what
else opens up uh your mind
red rock casino by the way big shout out
to red rock casino
they hooked it up so uh so maybe the
podcast before this so last week's
episode
uh we flew in my old boss my ex-boss and
i confronted him
and redrock hooked him up with this
incredible room so we booked the room
he shows up they're not now i'm not
saying if you book red rock they're
gonna do this for you
but i just gotta say uh we got there and
we were checking in
and they're like oh no sorry sir you're
at the vip
entrance we're like what and as we check
in the vip
this room overlooks the pool and red
rock is my favorite casino
in all of las vegas so my recommendation
if anyone is coming in to stay
uh in las vegas go and stay at the red
rock casino nelk there's a whole bunch
of different videos there
through a nice casino they got amazing
places to eat
and tell them graham stefan sent you it
looked really nice it's
really nice i almost stayed there i was
telling jack to recommend it and i guess
you would have booked already somewhere
else yeah
i almost went with it but then i thought
well i know i regret it i hate the strip
i hate the last video you don't like it
it's so well i like it like when we hung
out it was fun because i had
you know a shield to the horn
they're like instead they just look up
and down yeah listen you can't walk down
the strip
as like like a single person alone that
was last night you can't do that
i got so i mean it was an eco boost
because in boston i didn't get any
attention
because all the guys are like really
nerdy and they're like
women and then florida she's like
chocolate so here
i got like chocolate and there's a mix
of everything
thank you well this is the thing because
if people travel from like around the
world
just to come to that one area on the
street and everyone is
under the influence of something they're
going to say something they're only in
town for the weekend so they know
whatever they say or do there's no
repercussions they're going to go home
and like go back to their normal lives
but here whatever they do they can get
away with it
so you get just the extremes of like who
people are like what they want to do
like imagine like like people on the
internet you know how they act
like internet warriors that's how people
act in vegas it's like
the equivalent to being behind a
computer screen because they know
they're leaving like the next day
and they're under the influence of
something so that's i i can't stand this
trip
red rock is my preference it's beautiful
i regret not staying there and this is
not sponsored i actually do regret not
staying there and by the way this is not
sponsored either they didn't tell me to
say anything this is just purely me
thanking them
yeah in conclusion i would take track of
my little plane
or literally just travel i just love
sharing
my finite knowledge about the united
states
because i think travel makes you smarter
if not smarter
you're more open-minded like there are
so many weird things that happen in
where i live in my neighborhood and i've
just gotten used to it my next-door
neighbor's from colombia
and i would never know she told me this
amazing story how she's like
guess what i make 40 000 a year i'm like
she's like that's amazing i can sponsor
my family i can like
she starts crying i'm like there there
and it's just
i would never know to me that's not a
lot of money is here that's like an
entry-level salary but hearing her story
and how she came out from poverty and
she's just like i'm gonna be your auntie
i'm gonna make you like empanadas
and everything that's what travel does
or not in case travel but
just learning other people's cultures
that's why i would help
and i would teach you how to do laundry
and
you gotta say you gotta say now if it's
gonna corrupt you
yeah you can't just correct wait do it
just
how would you corrupt jack get it over
here we'll bleep it out if this is
anything over pg-13
yeah we're gonna have alex voice over
what you're saying
in a very pg way it'll be funny like
he's just so
happy he's just sitting there he's
always oh sorry
he just looks game for him
you are always very happy guys the
retention graph right now is insane oh
yes
let's keep going let's keep going down
this this rabbit hole here
i just feel like okay i haven't had like
that
much experience i would say however the
few experiences i have had because i've
lived in new york with really crazy
weird people
i know my type and i'm just very
adventurous
and weird
and i just feel like he'd be the perfect
project to turn into some like
super oh no um like a hippie guy no oh
no
he's so innocent i was talking more like
like i could turn him into someone who
would
enjoy making all the decisions oh my god
i see it did you hear that we don't want
to corrupt i like jack the way he is
that's
that's the thing like i don't want jack
to change i don't either
but i i want him to always be like this
happy
i i like the uh uh what was the word you
said before
just cheery just showing cheery i like
i like the wholesome cheeriness yeah and
i i don't want to see
jack coming what's going on man
get on the table
get that thumbnail done yeah just like
i'm looking at that way or too long no
no my god
i just mean it's funny like that's part
of that's the beauty of relationships i
think it's just getting to know other
people and just trying new
that's just me i'm just very adventurous
i think we're the opposite because he
kind of said that you
have kind of like stayed in the same
neighborhood for a while well that's
because i kind of have to
yeah graham you're holding you hostage i
took jack the farthest he's ever been
away from ventura what yeah vegas
vegas we we went to san francisco
have you ever been at one time other
than that where i've been to
the far stove yeah i went
to san diego
yeah but but you get to see a different
culture in las vegas
yeah it's awesome here yeah yeah strip
it's great
keep going keep going your attention is
good that's good
for attention yeah he's uncomfortable
let's keep talking about jack
because trust me the retention it's just
wholesome
i like wholesaling awesome that was the
word awesome but that's
that's the specialness that i i don't
want to lose that wholesomeness oh no
you wouldn't lose it okay let's put it
this way
i have dated only one person like really
long term
and then to other people short term they
were all really intense
aggressive non-easy going complete
opposite of wholesome finance guys so
they were always like oh
stock market oh my boss oh
really yeah the new york people like
manhattan guys wow yeah i mean it's just
you're kind of
he's cracking up i got used to it um so
because that sounded like me
up until the point where like because
i'm like to me
amc this morning amc did you see it did
you see game stop yeah you got to do a
video right now
and then they were kind of always you
know very
i don't know like it turns out those
kind of people
usually are the ones who need to be
babied all the time they're like totally
i don't know mommy mama's boys that you
call them or they need everything i feel
like it's the opposite when someone is
you know normal appearing at least and
more independent
uh i'm curious of what they're actually
like is it a facade
maybe maybe i would say that the biggest
thing is is jack needs to clean his room
dude i showed her my right now what do
you think is
since the beginning i don't know yeah i
thought it was clean
there's been a few times with the doors
left open and ramsay
ramsay looks in there and it's like
that's that's his time to go in the room
and then
i got to get ramsay out so of course
like i gotta walk that's not what you
said
you said whenever you walk by my room
you just can't help you can't help
yourself but look inside
both that's happened that's it's either
one of these and then you comment on it
too you comment
doors open i look in if ramsay's there
ramsay goes and i'll grab the cat and i
have to
step around you know land mines see when
i walk by your room i don't look i keep
my eyes
because you can't see anything it's just
a hallway except what
yeah exactly it's true well jack what do
you want to say about what do you have
any
uh rebuttals to this any rebuttals to it
yeah no i would say it's pretty accurate
i would say you pretty much depicted me
like as i
as i am i'm very easygoing i would say
that's one of my most defining
characteristics
i don't really ever have a temper or
anything i just yeah
jack and i have the nicest the sweetest
disagreements
the nicest things jack will come to me
after
mulling something over for weeks uh yeah
and i know because sometimes he'll joke
with me every now and then like you know
i know when he's serious graham we
listen
i i we gotta talk about something you
have a sack i
ah jack what is this so i was kind of
thinking
you know we got got this thing and he'll
just explain it's going around the bush
don't want to get you know upset over
this just you know this is what i'm
going through
can we do this it's the nicest thing you
could tell i'm like
super passionate about it too because
i've been thinking over it for like yeah
it's just like pacing but uh but yeah
every single time
we've we've gotten in some heated
discussions a little i would say
little not disagreements but uh little
tiny things we're always able to work it
out it's it's it's good
and nice very very easy that's good
would you say that you're
like aware of your baggage and
uh if there's any like what
what do you say are your flaws cause i
feel like whenever people are like i'm
easy going i'm fine
they're usually crazy my flaws or maybe
not crazy but just unaware of
well okay what do you i mean what do you
think are my flaws
don't say i see you smiling with
um gosh i'd have to think about this
because i want to give a real answer
yeah um yeah well it's nothing
work work wise i i don't think there's
much that i could
that i could talk about there um well
jack and i have different work ethics so
sometimes for me it's like
i have this standard of just like just
filling everything to brim
that's that's not jack so that's uh i
can't i can't complain about that um
jeez uh you have to think about it
that's good though why would you say
it's an experience thing i just
i just think the more experience you get
the more grounded you'll be that's all
but i don't think it's really a flaw
yeah
i don't think it's a flaw that's that's
probably it
i i can say the flaws i think i have
yeah uh
uh i i definitely think there are times
where i'm not very assertive
like i'll kind of just exist and if bad
things are happening
i just kind of act like they're not and
i just kind of cruise
but if i have to speak up i will as as
grandma seen you know like if if there's
an issue that keeps coming up over and
over and over again and i can't take it
i'll say something but i just don't like
arguing very much
and i feel like for a lot of the times
like arguing is
worse than actually just dealing with
the problem so i usually just deal with
the problem
what if it's something like i had a best
friend for
about a year and a half and i didn't
tell her
from the get-go that i thought she was
handling certain things in a really
weird way
and turns out it was too late i was kind
of just in that friendship or you know
it could be a relationship out of
comfort
and then it just came to the point where
it was just too much and i said look i
think you're crazy i think
you're super disrespectful to your
boyfriend everyone around you and she's
like
what you never said this before why
would you i said i don't want to be your
friend anymore
so like what was she doing oh
she crashed her brand new mercedes benz
that her parents just bought her
they got her new one it's because she
was texting and driving on the 405
freeway
hurt somebody else didn't care about it
it's just a repeat thing
she's an only child i'm an only child
but i was like
not like that i was taught them you know
how to be respectful i guess i mean
it just happens when you're in l.a rich
parents kind of thing
she was physically abusive to her
boyfriend she said it's okay he's a dude
he can take it
how how like like just hitting him like
role play red olive garden
[Music]
hey i would love some bread you know
what i really don't want breadsticks
right now do you think i'm fat
do you think i'm fat is that what you're
saying you think i'm fat no you think
i'm fat no that's not what i'm saying
look you looked at the waiter right now
you think she was skinnier than me
didn't you no
what oh you
don't you put your hands on me ever
again
sorry that was her yeah i don't blame
you yeah
but it's just that her boyfriend didn't
say anything and her friends were too
afraid to say anything and i wasn't
either i was like [ __ ] i want to get
slapped across the face
and you know when you let behavior like
that go on for so long i don't know
so that's my thing i learned that i
didn't say anything to my ex about
things he was doing that i thought was
unusual like he would just go around
saying like slurs that i thought were
really inappropriate
okay and then one day i was like you
know i think that's you shouldn't say
that he goes
what no way and i'm like yeah yeah
that's my thing it's not your job to
change someone
yeah yeah that's that's what i've
realized it's like you can't really
change someone if it's someone that i
really really care about that i've known
for a long time trying to go in
like the wrong direction yes so like
i'll do everything in my power to steer
them like back on the path the correct
path
but if it's someone that like that i'm
like friends with i'll just like i'll
just not be their friend
that's not my friend all this stuff
hanging out yeah just stop hanging i'll
stop texting you
that's i feel like it's you know i have
a flaky friend like that i just kind of
downgraded her from friend to
acquaintance to get drinks in a large
group so i don't have to
expect anything out of her yeah because
i'll be like you know get hit by a car
in the middle of the street bleeding
like
i'll just change your name kelsey can
you call 911. i'll be no i'd like
snapchat this guy first hold on
oh my gosh like i just can't rely on her
for anything
but i just know okay like that's just
who she is so i don't like to change
people
but it'd be fun to experiment just make
sure jack stays wholesome
does happy and wholesome we need those
two things
if either one of those is gone blaming
you
i don't think after now hearing this i
don't think he'd be the type to like
go into the whole 50 shades mode i don't
think so 50 shades
which is totally fine i've never seen
that do you know what the movie's about
uh i know that it's
it's um a very touchy
uh it's very like um physical movie
by the way guys we gotta talk briefly
and we'll get back to you jack don't
worry
it's nice we got uh bankroll coffee
you guys have always said that you want
uh you want to drink the 20 cent iced
coffee well guess what
after a year of mulling things over we
finally got
bankroll coffee this is the new coffee
it just came out the link is down below
in the description i don't know if we're
sold out yet
we might be sold out by the time this
post i don't know the link is down below
in the description bankroll coffee we
got a whole bunch of different
flavors of coffees we just done boxes
today it's brand new but uh down below
in the description
it smells really good yeah there we go
i love coffee i started drinking coffee
as a result of youtube
because i just find it hard to sit down
and edit a video
so it might be time to hire an editor
yeah we got to talk about that
sure uh i got you out of that situation
so you're actually considering
onboarding help
yes i don't know which way i want to do
it exactly
because i like the idea of having
someone around the clock living like
i have a huge townhouse i might as well
but i don't like looking for people
but that will make me more money when
i have someone who's a cameraman like in
my videos like when i did my home tour i
just light up
because i feel ah i give the old razzle
dazzle
when it's just myself it feels like a
job it's a chore
so yes i don't
i didn't have a good experience the
first time i had an editor because
it just looks like everybody else's
videos and there's a certain thing that
other people can't do it's just like
that comedic timing
but i believe that i can find someone i
don't know i've seen
your videos and they do have that like
personal
homegrown touch to them that i feel like
sometimes you lose that
yeah especially with the video where
you're talking about something personal
yeah and like of yourself yeah i want to
be like guys like my grandma died
yeah smash the like button with the
little like button
don't forget to subscribe that's the one
thing i hate it's every finance person
that hires an editor
yeah always says that little thing where
the little mouse scrolls over
clicks the subscribe button then goes
over the notification bell click why
don't you like that because
every first of all it seems really cheap
so much better and every single
finance person that has the same thing
it just
it it immediately screams you're paying
you know five dollars an hour for an
editor
overseas to go and do this really yeah i
disagree yeah
i think it just looks better it's
there's more to look at when you're
watching it
there's like movement and stuff like
that i like when i do it the little
little png file comes up oh bing i
prefer that
so much better i don't know if that does
that actually help your channel anything
huge
i've never said like or subscribe and i
think i should be saying that but now
it's too late they're gonna be like oh
you want me to like subscribe
your like ratios are crazy yeah yeah
you've had the highest like ratio i've
really ever seen
i would test one video and just
try asking people in a really creative
way not to hey guys
hit the like button but maybe do
something like you know what i think
that deserves a like on the video you
know what yeah
let me like my own video and then what
you should do you could do a cool
editing trick where you like
you reach over and like you press the
button yourself be like okay yeah that's
better we're like wait a second
something's missing hold on
just take it yeah something something
like that i think would be really fun
but yes it does make a difference i've
noticed uh when when i ask people to hit
the like button
it'll almost double the engagement on
our family yeah so like guys right now
make sure to hit the like button and
there's a portion of people who's like
oh you know what
i forgot to do it let me just do it it's
so easy to do
other people who think you know what he
asked i may as well just go and do it
uh some people rebel and they're like
you know what just just because
he begged for it he's begging for i'm
not gonna do it which is fine
but just the mirror act of mentioning it
uh
and then i've i've tripled the amount of
likes on a certain video
by either offering them something like
i'll show you a picture of a of a baby
clown fish
people love that a picture of an animal
or if i do a skit
or if i say like a challenge if this
video gets 50 000 likes
i'll do something people love that
because then it feels like okay i'm
gonna be a part of this i'm gonna get
him to do that
interesting i feel like no i don't feel
i read a lot of comments for some reason
right before my
i would guess people call it a blow up
in january i got comments like oh this
girl is popping up
everywhere i don't want to like this i
don't want to like her but i like her
i'm going to keep watching i won't
subscribe though like what was the point
of saying that
people just didn't want to like it and
then once they came in this girl sent me
an email
i just want to say i was in wisconsin
and like my my
wife my wife my husband and i watch our
videos and i thought that your voice was
really dry bland and annoying
your voice she said your voice is so low
deep dry and bland but 27 videos in
i have to say i subscribed 20 seconds
like i just responded
to your voice thanks question mark
did you respond i said thanks question
mark like thanks
and it was an email it was an email oh
cause i shut my dms off
just because it was just getting out of
control hectic people are like
talk about palestine like palestine wait
you got wait are you talking about
instagram dms
yeah just because you know when you blow
up at the rate that i did which is in
such a short amount of time
people expect me to not just be a
youtuber they want to be their friend
their therapist but also their
politician
their u.n ambassador i'm supposed to
talk about every single issue
everything if i don't that means i am a
bigot i'm like
talk about you know the parking spots at
costco i'm like oh do i have to
that means you don't care about the
parking spots the costco line like well
i don't know i don't go there okay then
they
bigot
because anyways my next video that's
true that's i've made a very clear
distinction i'm not going to get
involved
in yeah it's really anything
controversial outside of finance
no but it not not anything contra it
doesn't need to be controversial but
once you once you start taking a stance
on one thing
but you didn't do this but not this so
i've taken the stance that i'm gonna
stick just with finance i'm not gonna
get involved in politics i'm not gonna
besides kevin kevin's a buddy we gotta
support our friends
but besides that um i just stay out of
it
yeah even like that happened with
minimalism because when i started out i
was
very hardcore and i was also i think
just doing it just to kind of
defy someone i don't know who it was i
think it's just because
like i said my mom is total opposite to
me she's very unorganized has a lot of
clothes like super into fashion
at the time i was very boyish and just
not into it i think i was like look at
me i'm holier than now
so then i realized oh i do like shopping
i do actually kind of like hair and
makeup so i started accumulating things
and i made more money and people came at
me and said like oh you
have five pairs of jeans now you said
that you would never buy a pair i'm like
well
i'm wearing capris now karen deal with
it
yeah that was something that i i got
myself in a corner on that one because
uh i was well i still am really frugal
but but i was like frugal to an extreme
and that's what people wanted and
expected and then assuming you're so
extremely frugal
uh ivs
wait what that's true yeah yeah oh yeah
so so obviously
like half jokingly but i was kind of no
you were not joking don't act like you
were joking graham
you were passionate about it i told jack
he doesn't need to flush the toilet uh
if it's just a number one
that is true yeah i didn't do that
yeah yeah i mean i do because i live
alone it doesn't yeah but it doesn't
matter like if it gets because jack's
just by himself no one else is going in
there just
it could accumulate a little bit and
then you flush
i mean obviously if it's something else
you could flush that but it just it
saves water
it's good for the environment yeah it
does yeah but also i don't think my
lack of flush is going to help the world
but it still makes me feel good
but your justification wasn't that it
helps the environment your justification
mainly was that it costs more money
because who's paying the utilities
and you know what i looked it up you
know how much cost per flush
probably ten cents no no less than 10
seconds i'm guessing it's probably about
a penny a penny
one penny per flush so yeah that's what
i'm going to say is graham asked me not
to flush out
tlc i stopped doing that
yeah i i'm done with that all right yeah
and then what was this like a few days
ago
you said that jack i noticed that you're
taking kind of long showers oh i did
i did say that you're like the tlc
people like
timing though listen there's a there's a
water there's a shortage
and we especially in las vegas we can't
be taking these okay but that's not your
rationale that's not your reasoning
i can see it in his eyes he's trying to
convince himself it's a water shortage
jack
because we're taking a long
yeah but it's admirable i think it's a
great trait to be to be frugal because
you can't control it but like your
actions if you are frugal they tend to
actually help out because you're you're
more resourceful you're not
using so many things so that's good you
know like graham doesn't waste i
remember we went to yoshinoya and he
would take
that place and bring him home and then
he wouldn't use them
but he would store them so
i am a collector yeah the fine art
because you never know when you're gonna
need right when you're gonna eat sweet
sour sauce
oh you know what i had a whole
collection of chick-fil-a sauces
yeah that's yeah it's a staple you never
know when
you might need one i need to throw that
because first of all if i throw them out
then
it's a guaranteed waste but if i keep
them then at least there's a chance i'm
gonna use them it's not gonna be a waste
yeah
yeah my aunt is she's not watching super
cheap in alabama
we're in walmart which is the only like
place to go to socialize and
she's like kelly quick go grab some of
those bags you know when you're at the
checkout and walmart and there's
plastic bags she grabbed the entire
chunk of those bags
their entire supply took it home so you
could use them as trash bags
yeah i mean i use i use like eggs as
trash bags she literally took their
entire
don't you have to pay for those yeah
she's like quick i was like what dude
i'm like i can't get arrested i'll get
attacked in jail like
she's i wouldn't rest you for that
though yeah no but still she was just
like
we looked so sketchy and it was too late
i already grabbed the bags and i got to
make a run for us i've stolen one thing
there were
probably 30 bags from walmart and i it
haunts me to this day
walmart if you're watching you gotta go
back and replenish spend a little bit of
money
walmart you know make it up for them
yeah how do you plan out your videos
because you make them seem very
effortless like you just flip on the
camera you have like a bit of a thing
you're gonna
say or like like an outline of what
you're about to do and you just
freestyle it
i plan out some videos the sit-down
videos
i will actually have a notepad and very
like a rudimentary system of writing out
videos
take my muji pencil and my muji notepad
i write the title
like the last one i wrote is why i moved
to outer space and
there's an ongoing joke on my channel
but i just like hate everything and
everyone
and it's just me just being frustrated
again with the things i mentioned i'm
just so tired of having to play a role
to everybody and please everyone so i
said you know what why not just move to
outer space
um so i wrote it out i said it's gonna
be like 20 minutes long
first open the scene with me flying in
my cessna
really far out and have it fade i write
down like fade to black
and i write out open scene like i'm
gonna have a green screen
i write out the first few lines i just
think what will make people go
huh i don't know what she's saying i'm
just going to keep watching
like i do weird stuff in the beginning
of my videos sometimes i used to bust
out of my closet in my house
so just surprised people by entering
through weird ways that come from under
the desk
so yeah that's cool that does get your
attention because uh who was it it was
um logan paul's editor he has an amazing
channel
but he always says the first five
seconds he gotta grab their attention
so i usually try to get like the first
15 for like a finance thing like what's
the hook here
so you coming out like shocking people
doing something weird at least it gets
you thinking like
what's going on let me watch a little
bit longer and i think that's what the
lady meant in her email
she didn't mean it in a bad way and she
said i don't want to like you
she just said your channel is you're so
dry your sense of humor is dry it's not
making me want to jump up and freak out
it's just very
long drawn out humor and it might go
right over your head
kind of humor so i like that um but it
is more challenging if i don't
act more logan paul like like can you
act logan pollock
for like 30 seconds yeah yeah i'm sure
man like you know like i
you know i had beef with him anyway so
like this this fool right here
so he he so bro i heard you talking
about me i just want to say
i didn't really appreciate it you know
bro you know bro yeah
i just you know what i said what i said
i don't care that you broke your elbow
let's take this outside you know look i
don't have to find a channel bro like i
really appreciate your podcast and
everything i just want to say like
it's just not that was good
i can't do his voice i expected honestly
like the energy i didn't expect an
actual impression
who else can you do i feel like you
should just do can you do david dobrik
i haven't admit i've only seen one of
his videos but i saw his i see his
apologies so
you see his apologies
oh hey guys um well i'm
sorry i normally uh hold on
okay um i didn't mean to say the n-word
um what i was actually was saying was
nutcracker and it just it came right off
the tongue and you know i
guys like i'm just i'm dealing with
mental illness right now
it's not my fault it's your guy's fault
for making me so popular and i just
you know i just bought this house bro
and i just i'm so thankful for all of
you and this video is sponsored by
seageek seed geek sea geek
and you know just get your copy today um
i have a link in the description box but
anyways i was saying
i'm not a bad person i mean i've made my
bad decisions in the past but you know i
just
just this video is sponsored by
grammarly and i just want to say
i'm not racist i'm not i'm like yes i
pushed a grandma down the stairs
yesterday but she was just in the way of
my vibes and i just didn't want to get
in a way
you know it's just you just gotta live
your life and yeah
i'm sorry it's a life that was pretty
good
make sure to hit the like button yeah
like
like who else would we know that you
could do yeah the mannerisms yeah
the hair flip the hair flip was good
with logan yeah bruh
there's like name people i can probably
do jeffree star
he's gonna he's gonna attack me
i think he's funny i like him okay
oh i need to walk for this one okay
oh hi everyone okay this is my new couch
i know what you're thinking like didn't
you just get a couch yesterday but this
is limited edition chanel couch okay i
just got
tired of the old couch and i just you
know i just i don't like hermes anymore
there are mess couches
really out there i don't know his
channel very well
he's always buying stuff the hair thing
was really good
yeah yeah that was really good yeah
my sisters i feel like elmo
hi sisters so today is super exciting
here we
have maddie ziegler from dance moms how
does it feel to be on dance moms feels
amazing anyway i'm so excited to do this
video so we're going to contour her face
and i just so like what's it like um
being a dancer in l.a oh so far it's so
funny
okay so um yeah guys wow
i feel like we're just we have such good
chemistry you know yes
yeah oh my god so we're like best
friends
that's
he cuts people off
this is awful that was really good we
got to keep going
who else gosh your attention just
oh i've never seen a video of his people
keep telling me that he's like
suggested this is easy but like oh do
trisha paytas trisha paytas
easy yeah so like what's up
oh my gosh trisha you know you can't say
that
well i can say whatever i want like
what's your problem i don't understand
no really you can't say that i can do
whatever i want
no you can't i just think you're jealous
of me
and people tend to be jealous of me when
i go into a room they're just like
feeling the energy and they're like whoa
chill out and i'm like oh my god shut up
you know
yeah these are all so quiet you're just
judging me you're just
that was really good who oh you know
what yeah nato brian
oh oh yeah dude this is for you leaving
me on youtube
nate watches you yeah looking at that
camera i texted you nate
and you we had a good idea i had a video
to do minimalist cocktails with him it
would have been so funny
and he was like yeah never text me back
months later called him texted nothing
so this is for you nate
okay look at me now i'm on the show you
wish you were nice to me
you could have been a thing this could
have been your hospital okay
okay what's up guys so you know i
i just you got you got to finish this
i need a hoodie
hey so you know i just i know you guys
said i'm a minimalist whatever i got
this couch and
i can't it's too good yeah guys i got
this couch i know you're like whoa you
said you never spend money on a couch
but you know it's good
i can extend myself here i can also work
here you know so like oh and then i got
this truck hey man can you zoom in on
this yeah i got this truck
and you know it's just yeah i just i
feel like everything in pennsylvania is
just not really good for me so i'm gonna
move all over the map and go to
breckenridge
colorado tonight and i just i i you know
i
i i just you know i really don't
understand
that that's just him he just that was
perfect and the shoulders
the shoulders too it's just broad
shoulders it's over explaining
wow over explaining to make you seem
like you're getting content
but you are it's a process it's like a
cycle oh my god this is really i want i
just want to keep going i hope we're not
i hope you don't get
bored kevin kevin o'leary no meet kevin
me kevin why does it sound so familiar
is he the guy's right
your friend oh i haven't seen many of
his videos i don't know
all right all right all right now now
you're trying to imitate graham and i
think it's not laughing he's right
imitate graham and i okay i will do
graham first
okay all right i'm gonna pretend like i
just bought something
okay hmm
okay hey guys welcome to the 59th
hundred wait hold on which episode
60th hey guys welcome to the 1000
episode of the iced
coffee hour podcast my name is graham
stephenson today so far we made two
million dollars and
this candle oh it has just been my
lifesaver this candle
oh my god will you smell that jack
that's a pretty good candle right
you know this candle was sent to me by
one of our friends on the show oprah
winfrey thank you so much oprah she sent
us this candle is handmade
in where is it tibet wow thank you to
bet for sponsoring this video free tibet
people it's not bad
but it's the foot and then yeah
it's pretty easy you don't talk that
much when you do
you're always like pretty good questions
but it's
oh my gosh
[Music]
you don't do much but when you do it's
very specific
it's like what
why do you want to oh why do you want to
shave my head i don't understand
that's so good i can't oh my god
that's all i've seen mostly that's all
there is to it
that's just that's me showing one liner
one time
it's always the set and chill it's just
you can try to do me i'm so bad at
impressions
hey guys it's kelly okay hold on
i feel like a nerd hello guys it's kelly
stamps here and
today i'm gonna open the iced coffee
hour a little bit
go to the moon i'm gonna get my pilot's
license and
i'm gonna be a commercial pilot sometime
[Music]
how do you do it see i'm so terrible at
impressions i could try it's more about
the body language than the voice
okay because i'm always like that i
always yeah it's true okay
is that way too straight like that okay
all right
hello it's kelly snaps here
so thank you guys so much for watching
and one thing i want to mention that i
don't mention too often in videos
is that we do actually have a mentorship
group down below in the description
where you could meet with me every other
week and you can also talk to jack
every other week as well we do zoom
calls we talk for about an
hour an hour and a half you can ask me
whatever questions you want
it's a really small group so we have a
lot of one-on-one time so if that's
something you're interested in joining
the link is down below in the
description how about one final word for
jack
one final for him yeah for jack like
either a word of encouragement or like a
piece of advice or like one little
tidbit we could end
on i love criticism yeah you love
criticism yeah yeah i do he loves to be
criticized i love it
i need it see i told you there's
something in there
kidding he looks uncomfortable um
one piece of advice i don't really have
any i would say he was very respectful
when we met he opened the door oh my
feet were hurting
so much because my cowboy boots aren't
really meant for walking jessica simpson
lied
um that song boots are not made for
walking he offered his shoes
that was nice you offered your shoes
yeah he's really gonna walk barefoot or
try to squeeze into mine which probably
would not work then what would you wear
jack
i would i mean i had socks on dude i
would have just walked myself
that's a gentleman move i had never seen
somebody offer their shoes before
you know what would happen but yeah or
something no i think her feet were
hurting like actually pretty badly
though because she brought it up a few
times
and i i would prefer just to because my
feet weren't you have a different shoe
size
but at least it would have been like
some space something to walk on
yeah okay good i don't have any
criticism
i told him to do that i would just say
be open
to now now that you no not that
i mean that's it but um now that you you
know are
not in college and you have enough money
i would assume to like take a weekend
trip
ask graham be like you know what graham
i want to take a day trip out to you
know idaho for example
and be like you know what kelly stamps
is subletting a beautiful condo there
see
something else other than vegas and
ventura
that's actually a great piece of advice
i just think even if it's just weekend
trips just
traveling outside will open your mind to
so many new things
so that's more like a suggestion for you
and a comment for you
thank you let him lose him can't let him
return in one piece
thank you thank you for that and there's
no other criticisms really
i don't i can't think if i have to think
then that means
no okay there we go so with that said
you guys thank you so much for coming on
i really appreciate it thank you so much
to uh the candle for sponsoring this
video thank you
thank you so much for coming all the way
to las vegas for this video pleasure
now oh you know what you got to tell
them the smash like button oh
please smash the like button below this
video thank you yeah and the subscribe
button and the notification bell
feel free to get your free stock down
below in the description worth all the
way up to 70 dollars now for a limited
time you may as well do that it's pretty
much like free money
so thank you guys so much for watching
and until next time
okay